>> Cassie: YEAH, WITHOUT
QUESTION.
JUST THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
GAME,E,
RITCHIE'S GOT SOME TIME AND
SPACE.
DROPPED
THIS PANDEMIC.
>> Harnarayan: THANK YOU, SCOTT.
D
JUMPS.
ANDERSSON AROUND THE BOARDS,
OVER TO JOHNNY GAUDREAU.
SIDE.
IT COMES OVER TO MATTHEW TKACHUK
EVENTUALL
ZADOROV, ANOTHER QUICK SHOT, AND
IT WAS TIPPED.
LOOKING FOR MORE IS RITCHIE.
IT'S RIGHT THERE AT THE ZADOROV
GOT ROOM, DEMKO STEERS THAT
OVER.
HERE COME THE FLAMES.
COLEMAN A SHOT, AND RIGHT ON
C
>> Cassie: THIS LINE WITH
BACKLUND AND COLEMAN AND 18,
2022, SO A WEEK OR SO AGO, AND
YOU KNOW, HE'SBY BO HORVAT, AND
GOING TO TAKE'S TELLING DICKINSO
THE LEFT.
I'M GOING TO STAY IN THIS MIDDLE
LANE, AND IT ENDS UP BEING A RE
BACK T
LOOKING FOR THE STRETCH PASS TO
J.T. MILLER.
PICKED UP BY TYLER MOTTE, A
ANDERSSON,OVER TO GAUDREAU.
TO THE MIDDLE.
GAUDREAU SHOT
THAT TOOK VANCOUVER 15 MINUTES
AND 11 SECONDS TO GET THE FIRST
YOU CAN SEE THE HOOK
TKACHUK.
MATTHEW TKACHUK, HERE'S GAUDREAU
WITH ROOM, THE PASS M.
HE FINDS JOHNNY GAUDREAU COMING
DOWN THE MIDDLE, ANDBOARDS,
TKACHUK NOW PICKS IT UP FROM THE
CORNER,IALLY IN COMPARISON
TO PERIOD NUMBERSAVE.
NOW JOHNNY GAUDREAU L
UNBELIEVABLE SAVE BY JAY CAB
MARKSTROM WITH THE RIGHT PAD.
A QUICK TRANSITION THROUGH TO
UALLY GOES OFF
THE HIND HIS OWN NET. FEW PAIRI,
IF YOU WILL, WITH TUCKER POOLMAN
OUT, PLAYING ALONG QUINN HURAIG
BACKLUND A PASS TOY BRAD HUNT.
HE LOSES POSITIONING INITIALLY,
BUT JUST GETS BACK IN FR
BIG REBOUND.
CONOR GARLAND, NICE
STICKHANDLING THERE.
HAD SOME ROOM, A SHOT, REBOUND T
IN FRONT.
TIP, AND PUCK AND
HAVE THE CLOCK TICK AWAY, AND
THER LATTER HALF OF THE SECOND
PERIOD.
>> Harnarayan: SR JOHNNY
GAUDREAU!